visitarla al menos una vez en la vida es
un deber para todo musulmán la cava se
encuentra en el centro de la sagrada
mezquita de ahl haram en la ciudad de la
meca en arabia saudita
durante la peregrinación de lajas la
cava desempeña un papel fundamental
es considerada por los musulmanes como
la casa de dios en la tierra y la
tradición religiosa dada su fundación a
la época del profeta abraham tras entrar
en la gran mezquita de la meca los
fieles vestidos con el irham la
vestimenta blanca del peregrino
comienzan a caminar alrededor de la cama
recitando oraciones y girando en sentido
contrario a las agujas del reloj en un
curso opuesto al sol este ritual llamado
circunvalación es uno de los más
importantes de la peregrinación a la
meca en un marco de plata fijado a una
de las paredes de la cava se encuentra
la piedra negra entre las muchas
leyendas que rodean su origen una cuenta
que fue confiada a adam cuando salió del
paraíso y colocada en la cava por el
profeta mahoma durante la circunvalación
los peregrinos deben tocarla o almenos
levantar la mano hacia ella si no pueden
acercarse la tela de seda negra que
cubre la cava se llama quechua junto a
la puerta de recubierta de oro esta tela
es una de las piezas más preciosas del
edificio y su producción le cuesta
arabia saudita unos cuatro millones de
euros cada año en la parte superior del
bordado están tejidos con hilo de oro y
plata versos del corán y pasajes de la
bajada la profesión de fe musulmana la
peregrinación a la meca es la segunda
fuente de ingresos de arabia saudita
después del petróleo le dejó casi 12 mil
millones de dólares antes de la pandemia
lo que hace de la cava un símbolo
nacional más allá de su importancia
religiosa